hey youtubers is Charlie so the BBC has
just released a new trailer for the
Doctor Who Christmas special the time of
the doctor so thought it was time to do
a nice long preview for the episode
including a lot of the information that
we received since we got the last
trailer I'm also doing an ask emergency
Doctor Who Q&A session later be sure to
subscribe to get it so this will be a
breakdown of all the images and the
trailers that the bbc's released so far
so careful for plot spoilers if you'd
want to know anything about the episode
first the doctor receives the message
from Christmas town the town just
happens to be on a planet called
trenzalore
as you heard during the first trailer as
you can see in a few of the images the
town is totally decorated for Christmas
the image of Clara in the poster holding
the turkey is from her normal Christmas
celebration with her pseudo family we
haven't seen Clara at home since before
the 50th anniversary episode she had
actually been a nanny previously but
during the 50th anniversary she had
started working as a teacher it turns
out the message the doctor received is
actually a trap set by Tasha LEM played
by Orla Brady who you may remember from
fringe based on the soldiers she's
commanding in the trailer it's possible
that she could be part of the church the
Doctor encounter in the time of the
Angels or she could even be part of the
Church of the silence remember during
demons run the church was working with
the headless monks and the silence this
actually looks like a continuation of
that partnership to end the doctor and
don't forget the prophecy was actually
delivered by the silence and then
there's the rest of the villains first
the silence themselves the doctor foiled
their plot during the wedding of River
Song but the trap they said in Christmas
town looks like their coup de Gras the
trap is actually a time dilation field
whereby a small area is trapped in a
bubble of time that moves at a much
slower rate than time outside of the
trap as a result during the special the
doctor will actually aged over 300 years
the other villains working with the
silence in the episode include the
Sontarans the weeping angels the
Cybermen and the Daleks doesn't this
kind of remind you of the Pandorica
opens all the universes worst villains
trying to kill the doctor we haven't
seen the Cybermen in a while remember
they tend to assimilate things wherever
they go using the most advanced
technology available well what do they
do when they're stuck in an old-timey
town they use wood I can honestly say I
never thought I would see a wooden
Cyberman the doctor does have a few
allies inside Christmas town there's a
broom all MARTA and their son barnable
the doctor actually makes cloth stay
behind in the TARDIS so that she isn't
subject to the effects of the time trap
let's hope the
it's not a burm all that ends up
becoming that wooden Cyberman because
the mini war against the doctor takes so
long a lot of people wondered whether or
not Matt Smith was simply a gin to Peter
Capaldi but as you can see in the images
he just is wearing old-age makeup and
there is a confirmed regeneration you
can even see Peter Capaldi's face
blurred in the background of the poster
still though the mystery is the solution
behind the regeneration Matt Smith is
the eleventh Doctor but he's in his 12th
body look at it this way because David
Tennant's were generation during
journey's end counts as an actual
regeneration that doctor becomes the
eleventh body of the tenth doctor so
Matt Smith is the eleventh Doctor but
he's in his 12th body based on
traditional rules he's in his final body
so he will die in this episode unless
something happens there are two big
theories one includes the cracks in the
universe remember from series 5 I
haven't seen a lot of evidence to back
it up but there are claims saying that
the Time Lords are responsible for the
cracks and they're going to use those
somehow to grant the doctor extra
regenerations in the final moments we'll
call that crack theory then there's the
possibility that Stephen Moffat could
simply just create new logic that kind
of twist the rule at 12 I'll call that
Moffat theory and I think that that is
more likely because Stephen Moffat has a
history of bending Doctor Who logic
without breaking the rules of classic
Doctor Who I'm thinking that the
solution will be something that we
haven't considered yet but let me know
what you think in the comments below
what is the solution to the doctor's
regeneration going to be and what are
you looking forward to most in the
Christmas special besides seeing Peter
Capaldi for the first time I'll be doing
tons more Doctor Who videos between now
and the actual Christmas special be sure
to subscribe to get them I'm also going
to be doing a ton of Sherlock videos -
there's a Sherlock minisode coming on
the 25th - so get excited for that right
now you can click here to get that ask
emergency Q&A I'll add the annotation as
soon as I post the video and you can
click here to get my easter egg videos
for the 50th anniversary there are two
of them thanks so much for watching I'll
see you guys tonight
high fives
you